[Music]
so there was a lot going on out of
public view during the last election
a lot here's the latest example the
group judicial watch has just obtained
hundreds of documents from the secretary
of state of california our biggest state
those documents revealed that state
officials pressured the social media
companies the big ones
google twitter facebook to censor social
media posts they didn't like and that
wouldn't help them
about the 2020 election here's one
example a state agency successfully
pressured youtube owned by google to
block a video about
mail-in voting they didn't think it
would help the democratic party so the
video was blocked
some of the state's documents were
compiled by the firm
skdk its top client
joe biden soccer and jetty is the host
of rising
we're happy to have him on tonight sagar
thanks so much for coming i don't think
you could be a fervent biden voter and
still think that maybe this looks like
the end of democracy
or am i overstating it no you're not
tucker the most basic american principle
is to distrust the government youtube
google twitter many of these silicon
valley companies were built on the
bedrock principle
of free speech but this is a censorship
regime which you would much more see
in china i mean if you let's really
think about it the chinese communist
party runs
the chinese government which set creates
the sensors which are then dispersed to
the chinese tech companies
who decide that oceana has always been
at war with east asia
and that or eurasia i believe and that
is something that they
have come to live with there in china
this is something a one-party state like
california in particular
where the intertwinement of party with
the government
with the large tech companies who are
then listening and complying
with some of these regulations let's
think about it for a previous guest
brett hume he brought this up which is
that
dr fauci back in february was saying
that masks don't work so does that mean
that youtube back in february where i do
host a show as well
should have been taking down videos in
which i and some other people were
expressing skepticism
around this that would technically be in
violation of government practice and now
they're doing the opposite this is just
goes to show how dystopian this can get
very quickly well sure i mean google
apparently is suppressing photographs of
the governor of virginia in blackface
which tells you a lot so if you have the
most powerful companies in the world
working stealthily secretly to help a
specific political party then where does
that leave everyone else
well where are you going to go are you
going to create your own google i mean
they already have what 90 something
percent
of search traffic i think the most
bedrock principle
is this which is that when you begin to
see intertwinement of a political party
of state enforcement and then along with
the so-called private companies
you live in an oligarchy or and you live
eventually in a dictatorship
and the only way that they can have
dissent is that they have to crush it we
have two options we're america
liberty is in our blood liberty is
largely what we should strive for
and the other option is a police state
and unfortunately that's what we're
beginning to see
as you're talking i'm thinking myself i
hope a lot of people are hearing him as
he speaks
sagar and jetty i hope your audience
gets bigger and bigger thanks for coming
on thank you tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else